Hey guys, Jared here.
Today we’re talking about an Amazon— and
she has nothing to do with endangered plant
species or free 2-day shipping.
Wonder Woman wasn’t just the mega-box office
hit of the summer; the film and its eponymous
hero have become one of 2017’s biggest cultural
icons.
And, surprise, we have something to say about
it.
Now, some have called Ares a pretty lackluster
villain, but his conflict with Diana is pretty
interesting compared to most superhero villains
who want to just rule the world, or rule the
world, or rule Asgard, or rule the universe.
And part of what makes the Greek God family
drama so cool is that Ares doesn’t just
blindly hate Diana.
Their clash over the nature and fate of humanity
is, well, pretty philosophical.
So get ready to be lassoed by the truth in
this Wisecrack Edition on the Philosophy of
Wonder Woman aaaand cue the sirens.
One of the central conflicts of Wonder Woman
is, "do humans deserve to be saved?”
This makes sense since the titular character
is from an island of warrior women who exist
solely to save humans from destruction at
the hands of Ares, the God of War.
But as it turns out, when you’ve lived in
a tropical paradise with no boys allowed for
a couple millennia, you might decide that
humans aren’t really worth the effort.
“Zeus created man to be just, and wise,
strong and passionate…”
“That was a story, Diana!"
Much of Diana’s struggle is wrapped up in
the question of what it means to save people.
She wavers between a sense of duty, a sense
of caring, and a moment of Grade A apathy.
“They don't deserve our help, Steve.”
"It's...It's not
It's not about deserve!"
Meanwhile, Ares is fully committed to the
belief that humans suck a fat bag of popsicles
and deserve not only abandonment but also
to die painfully via chemical weapons.
“Ares developed a weapon, the worst ever
devised.”
Diana’s big hero statement of the film is
in response to Ares’ claim that.
“They do not deserve your protection!”.
She responds: “It’s not about deserve.
It’s about what you believe.
And I believe in love.”
And we believe that that line is confusing
as f*ck.
But instead of dismissing it as bad writing,
in good ol’ Wisecrackian fashion, let’s
pull it apart.
But before we get to Diana, we have to understand
what she’s responding to— Ares’ belief
that humans are worthless and can’t have
nice things.
Ares’ claim in the film has two parts: 1)
that humans deserve to be punished and 2)
that they don’t deserve Diana’s help.
“You were right, Diana.
They don't deserve our help.
They only deserve destruction.”
The first one is a question of something called
“retributive justice”— basically the
theory that argues that people who do bad things should go to jail.
So what informs Ares’ retributive mission
to destroy humanity?
He believes that humans are, by nature, evil.
“They always been and always will be weak,
cruel, selfish, and capable of the greatest horrors."
This is an essentialist view of human nature,
that humanity has inherent properties that
make them what they are.
So, people are doomed to be useless assholes
forever.
So it makes sense why you’d want to
get rid of them.
Ares claim is bolstered by the sum of humanity’s
actions over the last couple thousand years.
In that time, humans have done a lot.
They genocided a bunch of people, destroyed
the environment, and made this Logan Paul guy famous…
“Mankind stole this world from us.
They ruined it, day by day…”
So that’s the first part of Ares’ claim.
Now for the second one; one that is much more
central to Diana and the film’s arc— the
question of who deserves to be saved, even
if it is from their own kind.
This is “distributive justice.”
In Ares’ calculation, being saved from death
is not something that one is entitled to— it
is something that is distributed based on
merit, as shown by the actions of the individual.
Or in this case, the actions of the group,
spanning three-plus millennia.
This seems to be a pretty common idea among
immortals.
Diana’s mother, Hippolyta, tells her, "They
do not deserve you.”
This all reflects one popular approach to
distributive justice, called desert theory
which argues
that people deserve things— jobs, money,
awards — based on their actions rather than
on their needs or the benefit it would bring
to society.
Now, although Diana stays generally consistent
in her desire to help humanity, the logic
behind this choice develops and changes throughout
the film.
And while we see people justifying their actions
with distributive or retributive frameworks,
Wonder Woman goes a different route.
Diana is raised to believe that the Amazons
have a sacred duty to stop Ares and defend
the world.
So when she sets out for Europe, she’s not
doing it because she believes that humans
deserve anything.
It’s because she believes she has a moral
obligation to help.
This moral obligation carries her through
most of the film, even as she watches British
generals send soldiers to their deaths "You
should be ashamed" and Germans
taking villagers as slaves.
But at some point, she realizes that people
suck, and it wasn’t totally Ares’ fault
that they were bayoneting each other.
“Ares is dead.
They can now stop fighting now.
Why are they still fighting?”
Since her duty was to defend the world from
Ares and not from sh*tty humans acting on
their own accord, she’s not really sure
where her moral obligations lie anymore.
All of a sudden, her mom’s wise words sound
a whole lot wiser.
“My mother was right.
She said the world of men do not deserve you.
Diana is faced with a crisis of conscience.
She is no longer bound by duty, and her knowledge
of human atrocities lead her to the conclusion
that humans do not merit her help as a matter
of justice either.
Although Diana makes it less obvious than
Ares does, she is also motivated by a kind
of essentialism.
Let’s call this the “Battle of Essentialisms.”
Ares says human are inherently evil, Diana
says they’reinherently good.
While Ares never abandons his essentialism,
Diana does when she discovers humans can be
dickbags all on their own.
We don’t see too much more of this philosophical
crisis, but all is resolved by the time she
says, “I believe in love.”
At first it might sound like she believes
in the love of Steve Trevor, but that doesn’t
make a ton of sense, and let’s give her
a little more credit than that.
It’s only at the end that it becomes clear
to her— and to us— why saving people is
right thing to do.
What differentiates Diana at the end from
someone like Captain America is that she realizes
that it’s not her duty to help people.
She just wants to because she loves the shit
out of humanity.
"Baby!!"
Even though that might sound like a saccharine,
Care Bear cop-out, it isn’t.
While she leaves behind the ideas of duty
and deserving, Wonder Woman taps into a totally
different ethical approach that’s pretty
unique in the superhero genre- care ethics.
Care ethics focuses on the relationship between
the person who is caring for someone and the
person who is cared-for.
A good example: a parent who loves their child,
even if that child is terrible, or Logan Paul.
Unlike most traditional approaches to ethics,
care ethics rejects universalized principles
for how to make judgments or how to act—
everything is contextualized within the given
relationship.
However, certain practices are pretty important
like: respect, empathy, and attention to the
needs of others.
Sometimes these relationships are on equal
footing, but not always.
Wonder Woman is not our equal, so it’s
more like a person caring for a perfect puppy.
Just like you’re not born with an obligation
to care for a dog, Wonder Woman knowingly
chooses to enter a relationship of care with
people who will never be able to entirely
reciprocate, and maybe don’t deserve it.
She isn’t pursuing a defined goal, other
than making the world a better place, or holding
firm to certain universal principles like
Batman’s idea that killing is always wrong
or Captain America’s belief in The American
Way as long as you forget that whole hail Hydra thing-- she is
responding, as needed, to the needs of those
she cares for.
At the end of the film, Diana’s relationship
rejects a kind of distributive or retributive
justice, and instead makes a choice to love
them.
“But then I glimpsed the darkness that lives
within their light and learned that inside
every one of them there will always be both.
And now I know that only love can truly save
the world."
Diana’s belief in love isn’t a meaningless
platitude.
It’s a declaration of her commitment to
a particular state of mind and action that
guides her decisions as a hero.
This is clear in her decision not to kill
Dr. Poison, despite her being a war criminal
and also really creepy.
“She is the perfect example of these humans
and unworthy of your sympathy in every way.”
Although it would be a bit of a stretch to
say that Wonder Woman enters a relationship
of care with Colonel Mustard Gas just because
she decides not to throw a literal tank at
her, it’s indicative of Diana’s change
in mindset.
This is visually paralleled by Dr. Poison’s
mask flying off piece by piece.
As the wind uncovers her true, scarred, ugly
self, there is a very obvious metaphor, and
Diana recognizes the complex nature and individual
differences of humans.
“They are everything you say, but so much
more.”
Even though, by most calculations, Dr. Poison
probably deserves to die, Diana rejects the
concept of deserving, and by extension rejects
the Desert Theory justice that Ares is so
fond of.
Every superhero has his or her or its reasons
for blowing stuff up and saving the day.
Wonder Woman defines Diana’s ethos of care
and solidifies her role in the Justice League
for many franchises to come.
But it also draws out a frequent theme in
comics: the worthiness of the people saved.
Gotham doesn’t deserve Batman, and America
doesn’t deserve Steve Rogers.
Wonder Woman raises a question that we don’t
usually hear: does humanity deserve to be
saved at all?
And even if they don’t, should we save them
anyway?
Thanks for watching you guys, peace.